what you're about to watch is a special
private training session for people who
bought a copy of my book built to serve
enjoy
welcome board guys good to have
everybody back
uh today's topic was interesting is
giving yourself permission to live out
your purpose
um
man it took me a long time to get
comfortable with being up front
with being being the guy being
in front
i used to always feel like it was an ego
trip
that i didn't i didn't have to be famous
i had no need to be famous
i fought with my agent for years on it
and
it wasn't until i really realized that
sharing my story was actually selfless
that people could see themselves in me
if they don't know
your story they won't listen to your
advice
you know you look at evan there the
other evan
not this that we got evans back to back
but evan looks like he's got it all
together he's all figured out he's got
this nice shirt on and the pictures
behind him and he looks like he's all
he's got it all figured out and if
imagine if the guy who you see in front
of you is making videos about how to get
out of alcohol addiction
be like yeah but you don't understand me
dude look at you you've got this fancy
life you've got it all figured out
meanwhile
he knows
he knows exactly what it's like
and so until you share your story i've
been sharing his story me sharing my
story you guys sharing your story it's
not about you it's not about people
just praising you for what you've come
through it's about
other people being able to see
themselves and you
that people won't listen to me as much
for getting out of alcoholism because
that i didn't struggle with that that's
not that wasn't something that i had a
challenge with but evan tinsman he did
and so
if you didn't know that about him you
wouldn't want to listen to him i got
another guy tell me what to do he
doesn't get it so that's why it's super
important that you share your story and
and give yourself permission to share
the story
uh that that if you guys can pick that
up quickly that's amazing because that
literally took years for me to figure
out years of fighting years of pushing
by people close to me like my agent
who's like
just
frustration on his part i'm sure to
slowly convince me and it was until i
realized that hey sharing my story is
actually serving and we go through it in
in and built the server as well there's
sections on that but um
yeah giving yourself the permission to
do it is
super valuable and um
anyway i hope i hope that mentioned the
deal i hope that helped you anyway the
point of these sessions is yes kind of
lead with a quick thought like that but
but i want to be able to help you guys
out this we've turned it into little
mini live coaching sessions whatever
you're struggling with however i can
help
get your movement off the ground um
let's let's open it up what do you guys
what's what's going on and how can i be
of value who wants to go first
i'll go first all right let's go first
so i know that
when you first started you did all the
promoting and content for your videos
and that you know for your stuff at what
point did you hire somebody and now when
you hire somebody what exactly do you
have them to do like for if you if i
were to hire somebody in my content do
they actually create the content not the
videos but the content and edit
that's my question
so
the
first person i ever hired in my business
this wasn't my business right the first
person i ever hired was to do data entry
for me because i
hated data entry
and he was actually much better at it
than i was and so he took two hours off
my table and he gifted that to me and i
paid him and it only took him an hour
because he was faster and better at it
than i was on the youtube side of things
i the first hire was an editor part-time
and this really comes down to like what
do you want to be great at
well there's no right or wrong answer
it's the right or wrong answer for you
i did not want to be great at editing i
like at the very beginning of things i
like messing around with stuff i like
playing around i like seeing
the ins and outs of it and so i quickly
picked up movie maker which is probably
the most basic video editing
software that you can use so i picked
that up um got used to it but then
quickly realized that i don't i don't
like this i'm not good at it and i don't
like it
i wasn't good in front of the camera
either belinda i mean if you watch my
videos i watch it back it's like i'm not
good at that either but
i like it you know i want to get better
at it i want to improve video editing i
didn't like it and i didn't want to get
better and i didn't want to improve so i
knew that that would always be a
limitation for me that i would i would
force myself to do it if i had to but
as soon as i could get that off my plate
then i would so
the hiring a part-time editor was my
first hire and i think a lot of you can
you can you don't hire full-time you
don't have to just go out and hire
somebody full-time to help you you can
hire somebody part-time project work
um a couple hours a day or even a couple
hours a week depending on what you're
doing so it's really figuring out what
do you hate the most that has to get
done
and then and then working on that so for
me was editing now when i hire it really
just depends on what what the need is
right we've got 30 something people on
the team so
you know if i'm hiring somebody just to
be in charge of my linkedin content that
that may not be the best strategy for
you for where you're at right now
um but if anybody's trying to be in
front of the camera and that's where
your genius is then editing becomes the
fastest one so it's editing part-time
editor to then full-time editor to then
he got kidnapped so i had to get another
editor that was a crazy story he just
disappeared for for three or four months
this guy was super reliable always on
time and then like just dropped off the
face on the map and then he came back
like three or four months later and said
sorry evan
i got kidnapped
it's crazy crazy right i need i need you
know some personal time i mean i'm home
now i'm safe i was held for ransom um
yeah just
crazy but in that period like where is
he i'm sending messages back and forth
nothing happened and then um i found
christina my my current editor now who's
been with me for i don't know how many
years many many many years and then we
hired her husband um then i hired a
researcher so that we can
again like slowly niching down what do i
want to be great at i
love doing the research on the videos
but i love
being in front of the camera more and
spreading the message more so that i
hired somebody to help me do the
research
so you slowly take away the pieces of
what you don't like doing or don't want
to be the world's greatest at so you can
focus on what you could be
does that make sense
all right
thank you all right
good
question myself
fonda why dude i didn't even recognize
you with that hat on fun the white in
the house i love it dude that smile
uh but i was just wondering about
youtube and i know you guys said you
know create content every day
but i'm actually my youtube channel and
my videos i'm actually doing the editing
and everything myself so it's not
difficult to do it every day but i guess
there's ways to
i guess do it every day when you're
doing everything you know
don't edit
yeah
no like for your ambitions like fonda
wants to be a speaker
so
the skill
so if you're making a video how long
does it take you to a typical video how
long does it take you to record it
versus edit it and do all the other
stuff with it
recorded not not so long but editing
probably about 30 40 minutes and how
long to record it
uh i do little clips so each clip is
about my videos are no longer than
six seven minutes
so if you're spending more time editing
than recording you're spending all your
time
training the wrong skill
right
you want to be spending more time
speaking you're trying to train yourself
to be a great speaker this is just
imagine every time you pull out your
phone or whatever you're using to
record that you're on you're on some
stage
that's the skill you need to develop so
if i'm you i would
do zero editing
okay to train yourself that from the
second you press record that it's like
you're on stage because when you're on
stage you don't get editing there's no
editing yeah so it's a good skill to
practice look if you if you if you only
train yourself that i can only be a good
speaker and deliver a message when it's
been cut up and edited
you're never going to be great on stage
right
so treat every video like a stage work
whether you're whether you're in your
room there whether you're walking
outside you know whatever i still make
videos from my phone and my car from my
clients
nina's going to costco great
film
start recording rise and shine and since
festive time let's go
zero editing
okay
because what's going to get you to the
point where you can then hire an editor
it's not going to be you
producing a video every couple days
with your kind of crappy editing
right yeah and i'm i'm not trying to
insult you just no no i get it be honest
right like you don't you don't want to
be a great editor
so the thing that will get you to the
spot where you can hire an editor is the
speaking because that's what you want to
be great at
right so if you're anybody here who
wants to be a speaker you need to be
putting up daily videos practicing you
speaking erasmus got his hand up and a
thumbs up like every day i need to see
you speaking because you'll get
discovered
through those videos but then you get
paid to go do speaking gigs
but then you use that money to hire a
team to now help you edit the videos so
that they're crisper
but okay no editing is going to save you
if you're speaking sucks
right
and if you're speaking as fire
it doesn't matter what kind of editing
is on it
right yeah
it's like nobody's tuning out because oh
my god this guy doesn't have lower
thirds on his on his video are you
kidding me if i'm out
right it's like can you speak to their
soul that's all that matters
yeah so zero editing i just i've just
given you more than double your time now
to actually go and make videos
okay thank you thank you cool man
hi ivan this is iphone here sorry i'm
not camera ready it's iphone i welcome
my phone
i'm your friend
so i'm
i'm an international nurse and i would
like to write a book to write my stories
uh to what extent i should like uh
reveal my story at the other technical
um
part of my nursing experience what is
the perfect balance and mixed
to relate with my audience
so if you if you go through the thought
leadership template in here you'll see
that story is super important it's not
the whole thing like it shouldn't be
half your story if you're not writing a
biography but the story has to be at the
beginning as a setup
because before they're willing and this
is forever you know fond of making
videos all of you if you're making any
kind of content i have to know your
story and where you come from before i'm
willing to listen to your advice
so you might be able to say hey here's
how you do xyz which is what all of us
just want to teach
that's in our hearts like you want to
teach you want to help you know you have
knowledge that can serve people you just
want to tell them one two three go do it
the problem is people don't do it
they don't do it because you didn't
connect with them emotionally first
they have to know that you understand
them because when you give the advice
they just say okay easy for that person
easy for you to say you don't understand
me right back to the very top when it's
talking about evan tinsman so the
beginning is is the story so that i know
who you are where you come from that
you're exactly like me and then you
achieved and then the rest is going to
be
the tips the advice the tactics the
strategies of how to actually win
okay
daniel's putting on a new hat hustle
first all right hustle hustle or hustle
what does that say hustle hustle first
all right i got it yeah
yeah evan just said following with that
idea um
would you suggest putting your stories
out on a series of youtube things like
if there were two to four minutes long
uh putting your content into a story
over two or three videos or do it all at
once if you have a
sequence that you're going to put out in
an email for example or on your website
for example then that can make sense but
when people are just on youtube they
don't consume videos sequentially right
okay if you look at my videos you
haven't watched all my videos in order
i mean there's like
six or seven thousand public ones so it
might be scary if you've watched all of
those we have a little competition like
who's watched them i want to see your
watch history who's watched the most
videos from the channel um yeah first
off like a two to four evan tinsman is
already claiming himself to be the
winner
a two to four minute video is never
going to do well on youtube period
but if if you're if you're embedding it
on your website if you're putting it as
part of your email sequence for people
who want to learn about you that can
work
the story bit again i would follow the
model in built to serve you're trying to
teach but inside your argument is a
story that relates to it right and
you've got you've got time all of you
have tons of stories that you could
share it's picking v1 right story for
this piece of content that you're about
to talk about so if i'm going to talk
about youtube i have a story if i'm
going to talk about belief i have a
different story right
right same thing for me i have millions
of different stories it's finding the
one right story but you wrap it inside
of
the theme and the content and giving
advice at the end not just
your story and then hoping that they
watch your sequence
yeah yeah yeah because i like that idea
of having a hook at the end of it just
kind of say bring them in okay so now
you've heard me um you know how can i
help you that kind of thing you know i
want to be there for you
yeah
okay evan raise the finger
yeah i was actually just gonna share
that that um i just put something out
the other day i don't i don't edit
anything i just talk um
that's what actually i had a talk with
that family yesterday i'd mentioned to
you that they're actually flying me to
florida to help with someone and they're
paying me to do it all expenses from
just a little
couple minutes that they followed me
with my journey but
from that somebody else had chimed in
and that gave me the topic of the video
that i just did a short one today and i
posted so if you share something of
whatever your personal story is and pay
attention to your comments people are
going to start asking because i did one
on addiction but then that turned into
hey evan how do you handle like the
stress and anxiety
that's what led me to the one i'm doing
now so
people's comments will pretty much tell
you what they want to hear
i love it and listen try to try to keep
the videos focused
and every piece of content focused
you have a lot of ideas all of you have
lots of ideas lots of wisdom lots of
things to share but if you're all over
the place with the advice and the focus
if it's about addiction just keep this
one video on addiction you can make more
videos on other things afterwards it's
about having a powerful morning routine
then that's the video just keep it tight
and focused and then people will dive
into your world and want to learn more
about the other things that you're doing
but i love that i mean congrats that's
that's the power of like if evan didn't
just release his video
and fonda i know you got a client from
just your videos too on on on instagram
like somebody
you dm them and they they hired you and
what for six months i hired you now to
coach them yeah three months three
months three months like that's amazing
i love it like you guys are getting
business by just
putting videos up on the internet
right but you know if evan didn't
release that video because he didn't
have time to edit it today maybe he
doesn't get that deal where now he's
being flown to florida
right so
they're not hiring evan because of his
fancy editing and if you watch his
videos it's great he's either in his
chair there or he's in his car
and those are most of his videos
and he presses record and there's him
talking that that's that's what i want
for all of you guys to just release the
burden just make sure there's some kind
of light on your face right i mean go to
the window and have something in front
of you make sure you're not in the
middle of a windstorm or something um
super basic stuff but but you've got
you've got everything you need right
here on your phone press record and go
because you not producing a video a day
might have already cost you 10 clients
because you're worried about the editing
and that's not a fonda thing that's a
everybody here thing
raymond's donating raymond's done eating
we like it welcome there he's got erasma
you got a question or you're just waving
hi he's got a question okay what do you
got
yeah uh so evan when you say that you
want to see us like speaking every day
for us they want to be speakers
like how long do you think the content
should be or it just doesn't matter as
you go you get comfortable and it will
get longer
i want you to practice 10 minutes plus
10 minutes plus 10 minutes okay
if you can go deeper and go longer with
it great if you follow the template here
this it's a little hard to follow the
template by heart
uh
as you go through it yeah i know i know
i know you got the book i know um but at
the end like the thought leadership
template
it's hard to remember everything right
it's hard to remember powerful opinion
context sentence raise the stakes tell a
story three bits of advice
what do i'm just nervous to press record
in front of the camera
yeah right so at the beginning just just
think about the
getting that hook at the beginning like
what's your powerful opinion
and then once you practice that like if
you if you're doing the 100 video
challenge just once once you get that
down then the three sentences
into a story
and then after the story then you
practice giving your opinion advice if
you follow that template you'll have a
10 minute plus video easy
okay
daniel's daniel's holding daniel's
holding up screenshots i like it
um thank you
yeah 10 minutes plus is because great
practice for youtube
um but for every video if you just
narrowed down to
powerful opinion
story and advice
if you're like at the very beginning
just think about those three things i'm
leading with an opinion i'm going to
share some kind of story and i'm going
to give advice
right mm-hmm
so if if evan was going to tell the
story about flying to florida what's the
opinion at the top of that the the
florida story is the story and then he's
going to give advice
you know opinion
story advice
and as you as you get more comfortable
with that then you can work out some of
the nuances that we outline in the book
okay thank you another caller get
another call
all right raymond what do you got thank
you
hey what's up everybody sorry i was
eating i didn't eat breakfast i've been
on calls all morning um
something interesting if you don't mind
if i could share i just recently learned
and i haven't been doing my youtube
videos i had to let go of my editor
because we didn't see eye to eye and he
wasn't in alignment with what i was
doing
um there's certain things that i learned
like i asked him to take notes on three
different occasions and he didn't and
then he did the things wrong i said
listen i've asked you three times i
think we're done i tried to do it in the
oreo cookie where it's like with a
comment and then
you know uh praise and then
you know with what's wrong but
anyway i've been on upwork and i've been
interviewing editors okay working to
build relationships so i could do this
sorry
um on my podcast
and also one thing i learned i forgot i
think was from jenna kutcher that she
said when you do a video keep sharing
like i've been sharing it on linkedin
like every three days
and because they say six percent of
people actually see your videos
and so i did this
and i know they're scroll feed and all
kinds of things but i noticed just from
doing that if it's a good decent video
my second podcast is okay
but um i kept doing it and i just
noticed i would get more views and more
comments and people say dude cool wow
you know like you know engaging in the
weird ways that we do you know that's it
what's the main message of your channel
raymond
uh the main message for the podcast is
just
working with with people inspiring
inspiring us to become the best versions
of our stuff and learning from setbacks
failures and gaining feedback
okay great
so here here's the thing when's the last
time you posted a video on youtube
uh a couple days ago so the whole
fallout with your editor was recent then
yes
yeah well he did it like he edited a
week ago and then i was doing the
youtube stuff you know making sure it
was aligned you know being great people
you know to make sure i have the right
information but yeah it was recent
so so
i would say
it's i mean it sucks but that's part of
business yeah it means honestly it's
probably in the first you probably
already knew a little bit about that at
the beginning and you were trying to
make it right but it wasn't a fit
you know so so you'll be better on your
next hire it's fine and you leave with
the mission um
what's your one word what's your who
uh my who is freedom right so like
freedom you lead your upwork posting
talking about freedom how you're trying
to create freedom for yourself and
freedom for the people who watch your
content and how you want to you want to
build a
mindset of freedom in this company so
somebody who wants to have freedom
themselves you know that's who you want
to bring on so you're going to start
attracting the right people
but you can't let this be
a reason for you not to post content
right
so you have to post to youtube because
if your message is how to bounce back
after setbacks
you got to demo it what are you doing
you're not posting videos you're in a
setback
yeah the video was hey guys it's raymond
this looks
not like my usual video but i have a
setback because somebody on my team left
but i don't want this to define me and
not have my videos go up so i'm if i
lost my whole team
and i was using this as an excuse kind
of like my message wasn't clear
compelling like uh
i wanted to script it so i'm hitting on
points but i was i believe i was letting
that get in the way
you know and it's not that you can't
work on a better script and improving
but not at the expense of videos not
going up
understand thank you you got like
fonda's got to get his videos up
does he have an editor no so he's going
to do it himself or just no editing get
it up like videos have to go up
release the perfection
like evan even said just do like a canva
pic and then just do like a
a video and then that's it and then just
keep doing that until you know i will
fall into place i believe i believe
that's what happens tumbling blocks turn
into stepping stones but yeah 100 you
can always go back later too as you grow
and fix all your old thumbnails and
titles and everything else but the thing
that will get you where you need to go
is you releasing content
so videos have to go up everything else
is secondary
so if you're giving it well i could do a
video
i could do a video every day or i could
do a video every two days but have it
with a good title and a good thumbnail
and edited video every day
okay to start training that skill to get
better with that thing especially when
your message is how to bounce back after
a setback
yeah you gotta demonstrate you doing it
you're in the middle of it
i got a setback right now guys
and and whatever's going through your
head of like i'm worried that you're not
gonna like it i'm worried that it's not
edited well i'm worried that my message
isn't concise without somebody cutting
for me but whatever i'm not going to let
this hold me back do you talk about the
setbacks or no
yes yes okay that's personally
yeah like like dude did you watch me
make videos with my broken neck and like
giant scab on my face like every day i
made videos
with a concussion like not even knowing
what i was saying
yeah
no
right
i mean evan saw me on that tour where he
saw me on the first day where i was fine
and then on the last day where i ended
up passing out on the floor afterwards
because
it's just that insane trip that i was on
but i it was i broke my neck in two
spots and had a concussion and said i
was making videos every day and i still
even if it was for five minutes would
make
a video
okay with like a huge scab like
giant on my forehead sitting there in a
in this neck brace not even to be able
to see properly and like oversized nike
pullover because i couldn't fit into
this thing propped up with like pillows
behind me and ice packs
dude
but i'm so proud of that i still keep my
neck brace here on the on my shelf i'm
proud of
struggling through it is it my best
content hell no no that's not my best
content
but like i did it
and for people who are going through the
journey that's an inspiration as well
the people will see you and say wow look
he's doing it too
yeah because when somebody loses someone
on their team what are they gonna what
are you gonna say you say oh yeah i get
it i did the same thing i was like no so
you lose someone on your team you keep
going
here's what i did
yeah i mean i did i moved forward and
then i started putting out linkedin
intern ads
so i am moving forward just sometimes i
know it's slower than
but you're right video every day it's
always slower than you want yeah like ah
you know always slower than you want
everything is always so you want it
yesterday do it i want i want everything
yesterday it's always slower
and you get up and you keep doing
something today
yeah awesome thank you so much
i would say that's the best advice you
could give us for the week coming up i
mean if my volume is working why not
like throw it out there and give us
something to i don't know
just just uh you're right we have to
overcome struggles and poor struggle
into what we're doing and i know that's
how it works honestly the best advice is
like to
to get the content up whatever that
looks like for you not everybody has has
the ambitions to go daily yet that might
sound crazy for some people here the
idea of making daily content but if
you're struggling to make one a week
then one a week no matter what you're
struggling to make three a week then
three a week you're starting to make
daily then daily no matter what like
even just show yourself for a week
you film yourself there in your living
room making content even though normally
you'd be somewhere else with the
lighting set up and whatever like just
don't give yourself the out of
i'm gonna keep tweaking and keep making
it perfect having a deadline like we
keep trying to make our videos better
intros music
sources all of it always trying to hack
it to make it better and
there's no way that a video is not going
up today so when you start with that as
the basis like a video has to go up
today period
or if that's a post or if it's an email
or whatever that equivalent looks like
in your world for everybody here it has
to go up it has to go up
and then inside what's my best effort
and maybe your best effort is just you
and your room doing it maybe your best
effort means you can throw a little bit
of graphics on it maybe maybe you're
dead tired and you had a crazy day but
your best effort is you lying in bed
saying guys
i suck i'm so tired right now but i had
to make a video
post right and that's your video like
legit that is your video and you post
just to get it up
and build that muscle
whoo
guys thank you for the love
amazing super fun i have to pop uh zan
and i are on tonight if you want to join
in 6 p.m eastern on the gaming channel
um
yeah we'll be back again next week i
love
i love doing this i love hanging out
with you guys it's it's fun to see
repeat faces and also fun to see some
new faces if you're on next week uh
bring your questions again i want to see
you get your message out there to the
world because you got you got goodness
in here but it can't just stay here it's
got to get out there and we got to
overcome our fears and overcome
rejection and overcome all of our
insecurities to actually get that out
there so we can start actually have an
impact on the world
hello everybody welcome welcome welcome
this is really just we need to help you
raise your hand and i'll come in and try
to help who's got
a question a scenario a challenge that
uh could use some perspective on all
right denise is in the house what do we
got denise
all right i'm going to challenge myself
with this zan challenged me so i'm going
to
speak my uh my knees i love it let's go
this is great
so i um at the beginning stages i
actually just started with the movement
makers in march and
have been blogging for a year
so what i'm trying to do is to gain some
momentum in terms of my voice my you
know what i want to share is my mission
and translate that into a video forum so
i've done it i've
kind of touched a little bit of
everything so i've touched a little bit
in um i the ig world i've done reels
i've done a couple of lives with other
movement makers
i've um touched on tick tock and now it
kind of
coincides with the conversation earlier
this morning now i'm just trying to
figure out my
method
without burning myself out because i'm
my focus is work-life balance by the way
yeah burning myself out and teaching
you mentioned earlier you have a team of
42 i'm yet a i'm still a solopreneur you
know with just a team of ones so i'm
trying to figure out the best way
in a practical way being new to
creating video
of being able to translate things out in
the way that you suggested because i'm
new to understanding the video
world in terms of how to best edit and
and what have you so when i hear take a
10 minute and chop it in i'm still like
whoa that still sounds like a lot
so
um but i don't know if you have any
advice with regards to streamlining that
process maybe i'm making it bigger than
what i needed to be yeah well let's
let's dive in and listen the beginning
it it always feels bigger than it is
and and it is kind of big because you
don't have the skills yet but as you
develop the skills as you get started it
ends up being a lot easier just just
like any other skill like when i first
learned a snowboard i fell down 50 times
on the way down the hill and now i can
go down without falling down right just
like anything else
um let's start with this what do you
want to sell so you say you talk about
work-life balance what what is our
business what do we sell
my goal is to coach but ironically i
want to coach people to be able to coach
themselves um so so i don't want to
necessarily put myself out of business
but i feel like if people really learn
their way to internalize
their method for being able to live work
like balance they shouldn't need a coach
for their life they should be able to be
the coach for their life so that's
ultimately um where i want to get them
to but initially they may need to coach
and that's what i'm here for so and the
blog and what have you speaks to that as
well it's it's another forum to be able
to say how do i get information
independently
when i'm trying to do things you know on
my own great and the coaching do you see
it as being a one-on-one thing is it a
group coaching is it like a six-week
program with you where they learn
everything how are you envisioning it
long term i would like to be able to do
courses that's what i would i feel like
i would enjoy um but i'll be honest i
have come out of this is new for me i've
been almost 20 years in the hr world and
in that world i always had someone come
into my office and i'm coaching them
one-on-one so i'm very accustomed to
doing that and then also doing
like courses well
in that form it would be more training
groups small groups new leaders things
of that nature and helping them as well
and work-life balance always came into
those forums so no matter what you came
in whatever that you know the worry or
your mind was that boss that you
couldn't stand too much work on your on
your plate it always came back to
work-life balance and so i i feel like i
have a lot of
content to lean on in terms of my back
background and the world that i lived
before
and so i'm just trying to you know
translate that into these this new
mechanism
so coaching was what i was after
are you already coaching or this is a
new business that we're trying to create
it's a new business and because i've
always done my prior world as a nine to
five right so it's a new business in
terms of
having something outside of that forum
in order to explore
but it's greenfield so i'll say that
this is my thought coming out the gate
but um but as i continue to explore and
and find out new things in terms of the
entrepreneur world um i honestly i start
branching out and sometimes i got to
bring myself back in so so no well
listen i love it this is great and
you're great on camera this is awesome
you haven't even started making you know
the real videos and this is great
i love it so i'd look at two things to
be honest the first is actually doing
coaching videos so we're doing it right
now this is a coaching video
okay we just be flipped
where you have people come on like so
you know who doesn't deal with work-life
balance issues
you know at some point in their life but
probably every day right so you can help
tons of people
and
all you have to do is show up so when i
came on here
i'm like okay who's got a question guys
what are we going to talk about and and
hopefully you ask me a question that i
you know can answer as opposed to you
know gardening or something that's going
to ask nina to come in and help answer
uh so all you have to do is show up and
people are going to say okay here's my
here's what i'm struggling with denise
right say how can i help and then you
help them and that becomes content and
the and the reason why they would come
on is because hiring you might be
expensive or they don't you know know
who you are yet and so they'll do it for
free
because they're going to get the
one-on-one coaching but the the
condition is that this is going to live
as a video
so then it becomes okay how do you find
people to be able to do coaching
sessions with that was immediately going
to be my question yeah
and i just did this with um
an entrepreneur i invested into her name
is kira polson and she's helping people
she helps pull books out of people um
she taught in movement makers
yeah about a month ago were you were you
in that session i was oh it was an
amazing experience oh my goodness cool
okay
so she i mean i invested into her
company i'm a 25 you know owner of
helping her build her publishing company
up and as a part of that i said okay you
love doing these sessions with people
make them public and so now what she's
doing is a five times a week show on
instagram where she's helping pull books
out of people so if you went on you'd be
like okay denise like let's let's tap
into your book and she'd go through her
process and your book would flow out of
you just like it did for me and
um
i wrote my book 40 000 words in five
days and a member in in movement makers
today said he just started with her and
he wrote his first 800 words this
morning before movement makers started
and movie maker starts at 10 30 at least
on east coast and he already got 800
words done today he's like let's go this
is working
um and so it's
now she has his daily show where she had
nothing going on before
so
she gets people from
people who are already following her
from
doing events and then saying hey can you
can you do you want to come on and join
me live so
if you're on instagram already how many
followers you have on instagram right
now
oh not uh i'll say 50 plus
50 perfect so those are those are 50
people that you can send a video message
to to say hey i'm starting a new show
you don't need a thousand people
or or a hundred thousand people or a
million people or whatever you send a dm
a video dm
i like doing them while i'm outside
walking
um have you gotten have you gotten a
video for me at all ever
i haven't i have no not yet okay yeah
what really you're moving makers and you
haven't got a video dm for me
i haven't i mean i didn't i didn't i
didn't take it as a
neck i should have by now i mean when
how long have you been in movie makers
march i just started marching and it's
july i'm gonna i'm gonna message myself
and see why have i not sent a message to
denise
no pressure connor maybe we're not
following are we following you on
instagram maybe it's um but maybe it's
because it's under my business name it's
under curvy points is my
favorite points
i'm gonna look at this one so i'm
anonymous maybe that's i gotta look this
up you're anonymous your own account is
anonymous no no it's not
i mean it doesn't say denise so curvy
points
i'm not even following you
anyway well i'm gonna follow you right
now
so somewhere in there is a message that
got lost but
um yeah so you're 55 55 i'm your 55th
way to go right and so you've got you've
got
a lot of people so you've got you know a
bunch of mover makers already following
you you dm everybody video message i'd
like to do my so why we've been guidance
i like i like to do my video messages
when i'm outside
so i'm walking in the morning and i'll
message people
um and she's saying i'm certain in the
show
coaching people on work-life balance
if you'd like to be a guest it's free
i'm starting whatever wednesday
noon
eastern whatever do you want to be a
guest on the show and it's free i'm
going to coach you whatever you need
help with
and it's a that's usually the easiest
now you're already great on camera
you say that and i have such
camera phobia
i won't even i'll take up all day if i
start talking about my camera phobia but
thank you
well i mean i i am too before i film
and i've done
i don't know 15 000 videos or something
but the key is you just you just go and
like you just did it now you raised your
hand and you just started talking and it
was great just you're eloquent you put
together she's got a message it's like
it's clear easy to understand it's great
um so that now it's just a matter of
pressing record but it's a lot easier
when you're with somebody and you're
coaching so you don't even need you
don't need them to have um you don't
need to know in advance what you're
going to talk about it's going to be
something more like work-life balance
yeah but you don't need them to answer
20 questions before they come and go
live with you you just
say how can i help
it's the easiest kind of content to make
and
more importantly it also helps build
your coaching business because now i get
to see you coach yeah so
um
you know zayn's a coach right he's the
built-in the only bill to serve coach
certified
the only
the only momentum certified coach as
well
uh which is great let's go zan uh and as
much as zayn zen can go and do framework
videos
you know the
spell out confidence or the three c's of
confidence great but if you wanted to
grow his coaching practice you know the
best content they make is actually
coaching content like let's see somebody
come in who doesn't have confidence they
spend time with zane and then their eyes
get
blown open like oh my gosh i didn't even
know that thank you zan so same thing
for you somebody's feeling stressed out
overwhelmed doesn't know how to handle
their work their
their career their home their husband
their wife their kids it's like all just
insane overwhelm it can't deal
and then they talk to you and they have
hope
you know for the fir not even like a
strategy yes but even like hope that
they don't have to stay stuck anymore
because
you listen to them and you give them
what they need in that moment
other people watching then will feel
like oh wow like maybe i can
maybe i should work with denise or maybe
i should be a guest on her show
and then is the next step to that and
maybe it's just such a basic question
then just having that lead then in the
in the profile in the bio just to say
hey if you if you also want to enjoy a
coaching session this is how you sign up
with me kind of thing something so
simple
or is it better to have a little bit
more of an enticement of a um
a guy independent guide an assessment
you can do on your own or something like
that before
this is a two-step
process like you can't let perfect be
the enemy of momentum
so there's a perfect way to do it
perfect great but but it doesn't mean
zero until we get there
yeah so step number one is
just a coaching length if you want to be
coached by me or you want to be a guest
on my show dm me
okay you can do that today you know like
easy update that you know how to do that
you don't need some technical person to
come in and help you update your
instagram bio all right so you can put
that in great and that's a fantastic
start does your bio even say that you're
a coach
i'm going to say it says i'm a blogger
probably
yeah i'm sure yeah
i'm 1000 sure that's what it says so
curvy points blogger follow us if you're
a busy working woman looking to
transform your life and getting clarity
focused direction inner peace
yeah and then there's a link
and where does the link go to the link
goes to your latest blog and oh just
i'll blog uh
and then some spotify playlists
so i just think you're a blogger like i
don't know that you're a coach yeah
you'd have to go onto my
you'd have to go into my website and see
that i have a service page that that has
coaching listed which is so there's a
lot of steps to get there i see that now
instantaneously i see that that's great
well hey we're adding more clarity and
focus right now this is great yeah we're
doing it and that's what coaching does
right you're you shine a spotlight on
another people and where they need to
improve so same thing here like instead
of a blogger we're a coach
and
you you help people whatever it is help
people if you still want to do busy
working women cool
yeah deal with work-life balance issues
like
coaching on instagram and dma you know
something like that that you put in
there
um
so that we start building our profile up
that's that's today
that's the next step that's easy right
like you can do that that's not
overwhelming
the perfect step would be to have some
kind of lead magnet
that you're capturing email addresses
for
so
you create a pdf
do you already have a a pdf or bonus or
something people can download
um the only thing i've made thus far
just because it's been more commonly
brought to me is a a quick pdf on
building up your resume differently so i
do have that already crafted
um but that's just because that's
usually what honestly most people come
to me for it's not so much work-life
balance where they're they're suffering
from a lack of it and feel like the job
is the source of it and then looking to
you know change jobs right so most of
the coaching clients i have have been
there and so therefore i created a pdf
really for them that i also could use as
a lead magnet but um it doesn't have to
necessarily be the one that i
use for this form do you have any blog
articles i'm just looking at your ig now
do you have any blog articles on
work life balance
um so i so the way that i've i
structured it i don't have one
specifically just on work life balance
alone
i have what i consider to be three
pillars right so one is the fact that um
self-care as a priority
secondly is is with regards to a dream
dream job is possible
and thirdly that um it's it's practical
to have a work-life balance lifestyle so
self-care dream job
and the balanced life
lifestyle are the three pillars so all
of my articles
tend to fall under one of those pillars
and so there they're different subjects
but they all lead back to work-life
balance your articles are no joke like
you're writing
yeah right
no no but like i've been hiding in the
veil of writing and not speaking well
but sometimes a blog like you do 200
words and you have a blog post like
you're you're you're legit like that's
great so here's here's the easy thing to
do if you have your three pillars cool
you take some of your
your existing blog articles
and smush them together into a guide
oh okay okay
so the one i clicked on was how to feel
how to feel your soul and life
how to feel your soul in life and at
work so i don't that's a recent one or
just the one i clicked on
so so that's that's like one so if you
had your
seven steps or your eight tips or your
three ways to
achieve work-life balance this becomes
one of them so this is how step number
one feel your soul in life and at work
and then you bring that article in
and then you picked
two to seven more
from stuff you've already written yeah
and you
that's your guide okay okay
so now you've got a now you've got like
that's an e-book almost you've got a you
know 30-page book there
um yeah and you don't have to then sit
down and write it from scratch
so because it's a because it's a lead
magnet i'll say a freebie
because i always um suffer with most of
my content everywhere i put it is brand
new like you see something on my ig page
you're never going to see it duplicate
it twice and it won't be duplicated
anywhere and that's that's that sounds
great but it's you know you know
slightly it's messing up my work-life
balance
and it's just not and like candidly it's
not smart because like the ability to
repurpose the content
is a huge lever point you have zero
leverage in your business because
everything has to be hand done from
scratch yes yes where
your best quotes from your blog articles
should become
ig pictures and and tweets okay you're
like for sure
yeah you repurposing because
even people who have first off
you could you might be considering oh
but people may have read it already
right
okay one like most people don't read all
your stuff
right you haven't seen all my videos
most people don't watch all my videos
we're not that important right like
people if you're how many blogs that
people subscribe to tons
and second just because they've read it
doesn't mean they still don't need the
message
yeah so you're saying somebody reads
what somebody's going to read this
article every not somebody everybody's
going to read this article you wrote on
lighting up your life
they're going to read it once and then
that's it their life is going to be lit
up and they never need another reminder
ever again right i mean you know we're
yeah we're laughing but that's
that's basically the mindset we're
adopting was no people need that
reminder
even if they have heard it before which
most people won't because we're trying
to bring in new people but even on the
off chance that they have seen it before
the thing zen has up behind him i've
talked about that like eight times in
movement makers
you know and it's still valuable and
it's still a reminder and this every
time like there's still one more thing
that you have to
you have to remember
i'm so glad that you're saying what
you're saying because again only being
in the group for a few months
um i'll be honest even the last session
you might not like to hear this but the
last session i was like i don't think i
can go because i if i take him one more
idea i'm going to explode
i don't know how do i put into practice
all this data i'm getting and i think to
your point it's because i'm not
necessarily
utilizing what i have in an efficient
way in order to make it practical the
things that i'm learning
each session so i did i had to take a
break like after i think here was last
one and you didn't want him in between
i'm like
you just need a mental health thing
there's only so much movement this maker
can make
i mean i appreciate the honesty and i
appreciate you showing up here and and
raising your hand and asking a question
because you know a lot of people
when they're struggling do feel
overwhelmed then do quit and give up
where the answer is just build a little
bit of momentum
yeah so in any training whether it's
mine or anybody else's it's like take
one piece and just do something on it
like if you help somebody with a
work-life balance and you create
an entire beautiful life for them
the path to get there feels overwhelming
and daunting and impossible and
true maybe the next step is okay like
just take 20 minutes a day to breathe
yeah or just go have that one
conversation with your husband or just
like put up a little bit of the defense
at work
or just like
it's amazing to think about the life
they could build but we're stuck
in the how and it's just so overwhelming
that then they do nothing
and so the most important thing is just
the momentum to build up that's why
we're doing the
momentum challenge coming up because
it's more most people are stuck even
achievers is where you're stuck
um
so yeah so the coaching
series
ideally leads to a lead magnet
making lead magnets easy because you
already have all the content you just
gotta package it together
and then that's where
once you have your email address you can
do a lot more that's where you can
promote your coaching that's where if
you need more guests for your show
that's where if you have like when i
have my my momentum challenge ken up
we're going to email people
who've watched my videos who've
downloaded my lead magnets so that they
know about the challenge that's coming
up
if if we go from
instagram video or coaching session
right to dm me
it's almost like you're getting married
on the first date
right which which will happen like some
people will just do it because they need
it they love what they're ready but most
people
don't want to take that biggest step at
the beginning they're like denise okay i
like her vibe who is she no she's got
this free thing okay let me go check
that out before i'm going to commit to
coming on even if you think about you
showing up here
you're in movement makers you've been
here since march so we're like months in
now
you're
you've seen my stuff and know me but
it's like if zan didn't push you would
you have raised your hand that quickly
absolutely not absolutely not right
so but so like one yay for zayn let's
like collect people and and it's great
to be around people who who push you to
want to be better
but now imagine people watching your
stuff
there's resistance to dming you where
they might have to watch a few of your
episodes first they'd be like oh i don't
know dm or not you know i'm struggling
but i don't know
just how many and hein right yeah and so
the way to shortcut that is instead of
having them to have to dm you they get
the free
pdf bonus but then you can build the
relationship through email
send them send them valuable videos send
them content
build the know like trust like denise is
the woman for me she can help me okay
now i'll come on her show
so that's
that's the perfect that's the ideal that
we're building towards is some kind of
lead magnet capture but
today we update our bio and say
yeah that's it dm me
yeah
and then and then for the content
um i would mix in both coaching even
when i said today in movie makers you
have one
ig live per a week
so ideally you're doing like a coaching
session at least once some of the move
makers go live every day which works too
but
again let's not overwhelm ourselves and
you know stress out
but one ig live coaching per week
and then one video per week of you
sharing
some of your methodologies some of
things you've learned
um even if you don't cut it up and put
it through their platforms yet even if
you just post it on youtube because the
first ones it took me two days to make
one video at the beginning
now i i didn't have a mentor i
overthought everything i was in my suit
and you know i had to memorize
everything and yeah but but you it'll
become faster as you put in more
repetition just like anything else yeah
so
it may
feel impossible to make
10 videos in a day right now but you'll
be able to get there
yeah and it won't take as much time
right like 10 videos might take you 10
days to make right now
yeah so it feels like there's no way i
can overcome that hurdle
but
so don't stress about it because as you
get better at it and you figure out the
skill sets
and you got family supporting you and
you know we're here to cheer you on and
give you love community and like post to
movement makers um
then it'll become a lot faster so as a
starting point just
book book a guest for your show reach
out send send the video dms
update your instagram bio yeah and even
that
like it's it's momentum
and that feels like a big step and it
that's that's a huge step that's a huge
step
and worth like you know high-fiving
yourself or like pat yourself on the
back you took that huge step it's
amazing
and
after that huge step is once you get
used to that it's like okay i'm ready
for my next step
yeah yeah i guess i made that also too
big in my mind because i had seen
someone some time ago
who um didn't coach well i guess there
was coaching they had open forum
questions uh you know people coming in
and thinking how in the world do you do
that how do you get people
to come in and they did they're slightly
different it was almost like a um a
phone in session but they still did it
um you know via ig and i was just so
confused like how in the world i don't
know enough to know how to get that
opportunity but i feel like as you've
already mentioned
if anybody came and just had anything on
their heart with regards to work-life
balance even if they didn't see it as
that was the issue they had but i i have
complete confidence in myself that i'd
be able to identify and say hey and
let's talk through this and let me see
let me show you what i see let me listen
first and foremost but then as i'm
listening let me let me give you a
different view on it and i just was so
anxious to find that form because again
working in an hr office people just come
to you i don't have to do that you know
it just came they came in and asked for
a form
and somehow we were having an hour-long
conversation about their life so
to be able to translate that into an ig
forum i'm like i don't know how to do it
but i just so desperately feel like it
would be worthwhile to do
and it will get to the point where
people will just come
yeah and at the beginning
you you even me when i started my ig
live show i booked the first five guests
i messaged in person say hey i'm
starting a new show you want to be a
guest on my show
yeah coaching helping out whatever
problem you have around entrepreneurship
something i can answer for you
you know great i'm not coming in talking
about hair care products
right so you know something i can help
with uh and then if you continue on
it'll become its own thing where people
will want to come on
but you you booked the first
guests and you say i'll i'll be on
tomorrow
at noon come join me
and even if it's just the two of you and
like nobody's watching yet cool like
you're still helping that one person and
it's still valuable and it still gives
you content that you can use for years
and it's it's it's a human like you're
still going to add value you're going to
pour into this other human who's
struggling with something right now and
they're going to get value from it
and it'll still feel good because now
it's like i help somebody today yeah
yeah just the whole point
let's go denise
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there i'll see you there
i'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love